- So Amber Heard's attorney
objected to his own question.
I gotta see this.
- You were not informed
as to what caused damage
to Mr. Depp's hand, finger on March 8th?
- Okay. So that's hearsay.
- Objection, hearsay.
- He's objecting to hearsay.
You're asking what they were told.
- Sustain the objection.
Next question.
- You didn't know what could cause damage
to Mr. Depp's hand while
you were there on March 8th.
- That's an ambiguous question.
You can know something
by being told something
or just viewing it firsthand.
- Dr. Gabriel told me
he sustained an injury
on one of his fingers.
- Objection. Hearsay.
- You asked the question.
- Oh boy.
The problem here is that he
asked an ambiguous question
that elicited a hearsay response.
I mean, it's complicated.
It might not be hearsay,
that's a different issue.
And it's not that he
objected to his own question,
it's that he objected to the testimony.
What he should have done is made a motion
to the court to strike
the answer as hearsay,
but effectively, the judge is saying,
you asked the question,
it might not be hearsay
so you can live with the answer.
And everyone is exasperated here.
It's not the finest
lawyering I've ever seen
but being a trial lawyer is hard.
You only have a split
second, and this is a totally
normal thing that happens all the time.
albeit phrased in an
unfortunate way that kind of
makes this lawyer look bad.